what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch today
from Pixar the teaser trailer for the
film Elemental and of course joining
me today's co-host John how are you John I'm
feeling animated how are you sir I'm feeling
animated too ladies and Gentlemen please go
ahead and leave a like that helps us out in
the algorithm and also go ahead and subscribe
and click that notification Bell also because
uh got some reactions to some movies coming
up a Decor line that's going up tomorrow
gonna be shooting with a return against Sarah
Erickson for the movie disenchanted and then
there's some other ones in the works that you
might be surprised I haven't seen yet but hey
just keep a lookout for that alrighty let's
see what the elemental trailer is all about
the 27th Pixar movie
so they can't die now
element City
hi oh it's got like that Soul animation Earth
people water people air people fire people
the universes have to be connected I mean
come on look at this yeah that's cool
no oh
I like that that's about good visual
comedy go ahead and Breakers oh
oh you're dangerous to be around sorry
Amber to meet you Wade and Ember
opposites react oh wow wow wow well that looks
beautiful John what are your first thoughts yeah
it looked really gorgeous and a very easy way to
introduce us to what this new world is gonna be
like what if the different elements of our natural
world had feelings yeah um but yeah I mean I loved
just this little Glimpse at the design at the
world at the different people and character
designs and whatnot uh yeah the animation looks
really beautiful really stylized certainly but
also just so tangible with the textures and
especially when you're looking through the water
when you're looking at the Flames uh the Earth's
characters with the plant you know life and all
that stuff is uh it's quite beautiful and I think
you're on to something there with like the being
that this seems to be another faculty of just
the existence of the natural world it's got to
be happening somewhere in a similar plane to stuff
like uh you know soul and maybe even inside out
what did you think yeah I feel like that all those
theories about connecting to the fix our universe
I've got to be true to some extent because I'm
looking at the animation I'm like yeah this seems
very reminiscent of other films that have come
before it within the Pixar Camp I'm about to
confess something to you guys I've only kind of
seen inside out what happened is without saying
anything that'll get me in trouble with YouTube
Community guidelines it is I hate a certain
something ah that um 20 minutes in I've passed
out and uh I don't remember what I saw he took
a melatonin that's yeah we'll say that what that's
called yeah yeah yeah so I'm like when people talk
about inside out it's usually a lot of nodding my
head yep I'm like I have no idea what happened so
yeah that's one of the movies I want to react
to without eating anything prior but uh yeah
looking this up on Disney Wiki uh the synopsis for
this is in a city where fire water land and air
residents live together her a fiery young woman
and a go with the flow guy who I'm imagining is
that water guy Wade are about to discover
something Elemental how much they actually
have in common oh snap is that like inside out
I imagine um I mean something about emotions
it's more like you have a character experiencing
things and then you zap inside their head to see
what all their different uh spectrum of emotions
are doing to control don't go too far here
it's okay this is by the director of the good
dinosaurs you're in for something totally I have
seen the good dinosaur and I actually enjoyed that
movie I feel like that movie's not appreciated
enough but yeah I mean I feel like this will be
one of those movies I will probably have I'm not
familiar with these actors uh Leia Lewis and I
know I'm pronouncing it wrong namadu mamodu athi
I'm not familiar with them but it's cool to get
you know an animated movie where the voice actors
are not like super famous celebrities you know I'm
sure they have work that probably some of you guys
are very much familiar with I'm personally not
but usually it looks like they try to slap on
like really famous names in there that everyone
knows and I like that they're just relying on the
Pixar name for this and with the idea of exploring
elements I feel like this is kind of a that's it's
a common property exploration they've done before
like oh these characters represent elements and
what do those what are those personalities
and even though a lot of the time they can
feel like they are opposing but finding out the
similarities and how they kind of necessitate each
other in terms of balance and also that you can't
really exist without the other I like the idea of
exploring that through this animated medium that
is the glory of Pixar so I imagine that like many
of these great Pixar movies that there'll probably
be a lot of funny moments in there that they'll
probably be some just yeah absolutely adventurous
sweeping times but perhaps get emotional and
then you know I like I like when Pixar goes a
little bit ethereal I like when they go into this
dreamlike realm you know Seoul was my favorite
movie of the year that it came out and I'm
enjoying what I'm seeing so far I'm curious to see
what kind of the musical influences are because
I got a little bit of like into the spider-verse
fives for some reason when she goes onto the train
and puts the headphones on because clearly there's
there's something about her being fire that seems
like she can't just be herself like she has to
be hidden like there's there's this the the sense
that I was getting is that she's not accepting
of herself just because of the fact that she has
to remain hidden and seems a little bit Meek even
though she can be like explosive and dangerous and
kind of like a Rogue X-Men situation well yeah
I wonder if maybe that's a thing for the fire
people of this world in general yes maybe you're
you know more prone than any of the other elements
to Accidental destruction or or lashing out in
ways you didn't maybe intend to and I bet there
will be a personal journey to be learned from that
and I'm sure that you know Wade will probably need
to learn maybe to conduct the flow and not just go
with the flow true yeah they could learn from each
other absolutely opposites react this year 2023.
Democrats versus Republicans let's get it going
guys alrighty well what did you guys think of this
Elemental trailer leave your thoughts down below
uh go ahead subscribe click that Bell leave a like
last but not least let's send this with a patreon
it's only fitting that we shout out Everett pixel
might Baker might considering that this is a movie
made of pixels here that's right um but Everett
looking at your patreon account it seems that
you have been here for 51 months you have been
baking that pledge like 12 times 4 is 48 so yeah
four four years in three months that's a good
amount of time man it's almost ready it's hot
and gooey that pledge thank you so much for being
here for for like that that is a commitment so
um I really really appreciate it we both
do and I want you to have a happy holiday
season and I hope that you're able to spend
time with loved ones and family and you know
friends whoever may be pets the internet
you know go on some sites pay to you some
things I don't really know what you got to do
to make yourself feel good but do whatever it
takes to feel good because you deserve it
thank you friend we'll talk with you soon